HOW TIFFANY GISH LEFT THREE
VOICEMAILS FOR JUDGE CANNON
THREATENING TO HAVE HER
ASSASSINATED IN FRONT OF HER
FAMILY.
>>> TOMORROW THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES RETURNS TO WORK
ON CAPITOL HILL AS THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE WORK RAMPS UP.
I SPOKE WITH LIZ CHENEY OF
WYOMING, ASKED HER ABOUT
REPORTING TODAY ON FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REFUSAL TO
ACCEPT THE 2020 ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> MAGGIE HABERMAN OF "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" HAS A NEW BOOK
COMING OUT AND AMONG THE MANY
SCOOPS IN HER BOOK ARE THE FACT
THAT DONALD TRUMP TOLD AIDES IN
THE DAYS FOLLOWING HIS LOSS IN
THE ELECTION THAT HE WAS GOING
TO JUST STAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
ONE OF THE QUOTES, QUOTE I'M
JUST NOT GOING TO LEAVE.
ANOTHER QUOTE, WE'RE NEVER
LEAVING, HOW CAN YOU LEAVE WHEN
YOU WON AN ELECTION.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> YOU KNOW, I OBVIOUSLY HAVEN'T
SEEN HER BOOK.
BUT SOMETIMES PEOPLE WILL SAY
WELL, YOU KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED
WASN'T THAT BIG A DEAL BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, IF MIKE PENCE HAD
REJECTED A SLATE OF ELECTORS THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD HAVE SORTED
IT OUT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS PEOPLE
SAY THIS WASN'T AS DANGEROUS AS
IT REALLY WAS.
AND WHEN YOU HEAR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, I THINK YOU HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WERE IN
NO-MAN'S LAND.
AND TERRITORY WE'VE NEVER BEEN
IN BEFORE AS A NATION.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT, WELL,
THE SUPREME COURT WOULD HAVE
SORTED IT OUT, YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF BUT WHO WOULD HAVE
ENFORCED THE RULINGS OF A COURT
AND IF YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
REFUSING TO LEAVE THE WHITE
HOUSE OR SAYING HE REFUSES TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE, THEN
ANYONE WHO SORT OF STANDS ASIDE
AND SAYS SOMEONE ELSE WILL
HANDLE IT, IS THEMSELVES PUTTING
THE NATION AT RISK.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IT'S CLEAR
THAT WHEN YOU'RE AT A MOMENT
THAT WE FACED, EVERYONE HAS TO
STAND UP AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I THINK THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT THOSE ARE THE
SENTIMENTS THAT, YOU KNOW, HE
REPORTEDLY EXPRESSED.
I THINK, AGAIN, IT JUST AFFIRMS
THE REALITY OF THE DANGER.
>> AND YOU CAN SEE MORE OF MY
INTERVIEW WITH CONGRESSWOMAN
CHENEY AND MANY, MANY OTHERS IN
A BRAND NEW CNN SPECIAL, IT'S
CALLED "AMERICAN COUP THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION" THAT
AIRS SUNDAY NIGHT AT 9:00
EASTERN ONLY HERE ON CNN.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS SET TO
MEET TOMORROW TO DISCUSS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT DECISIONS
YET, WHETHER TO REQUEST FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE APPEAR BEFORE
THE PANEL.
THIS WOULD BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
ARE EITHER TRUMP OR PENCE
EXPECTED TO TESTIFY IF ASKED?
>> THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DON'T
HAVE HIGH HOPES THAT EITHER
GENTLEMAN WOULD SHOW UP AND
PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL LOVE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED IF MIKE PENCE WAS
UP THERE.
BUT THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T THINK
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
THEY THINK THEY MAY WANT TO
ESTABLISH THE RECORD, SHOW THEY
REACHED OUT TO THE MEN, SOUGT
THEIR TESTIMONY AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT IF THEY MOVE FORWARD
WITH CRIMINAL REFERRALS RELATED
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THEY
THEN ESTABLISHED A RECORD AROUND
TRYING TO TALK TO TRUMP AND HIS
TOP DEPUTY, THE VP.
>> AND GLORIA, VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE HAS NOT RULED OUT HE WOULD
TESTIFY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
LAST MONTH HE SAID SHE WOULD
CONSIDER AN INVITATION FROM THE
PANEL.
HOW SERIOUSLY DO YOU TAKE THAT?
>> NOT VERY SERIOUSLY.
I THINK HE'S NOT GOING TO SAY
I'M NOT GOING TO CONSIDER IT.
BUT FROM MY SOURCES IN PENCE
WORLD, IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS
NEEDLE HAS NOT MOVED AT ALL.
THE COMMITTEE IS GOING TO MEET,
THEY'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT,
AS SARAH IS SAYING, THEY'RE
GOING TO WANT TO DO IT FOR THE
HISTORIC RECORD AND SAY HOW CAN
YOU HAVE AN INVESTIGATION AND
NOT EVEN ASK THESE TWO MEN TO
TESTIFY.
THEY DON'T EXPECT A POSITIVE
ANSWER, BUT AT LEAST THEY THINK
THEY NEED TO DO IT.
AND I THINK PENCE WORLD
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE ALSO
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE ANSWER IS
GOING TO BE.
>> SARA, COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HINTED THAT THE PANEL IS GOING
TO TAKE A VOTE AND DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR
DONALD TRUMP OR ANYONE ELSE.
WHERE DOES THE COMMITTEE STAND
ON THAT VOTE AS OF NOW?
>> THIS IS A POINT OF DISCUSSION
IN THE COMMITTEE, ONE OF THE
THINGS THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN
THEIR FINAL MONTHS OF WORK, AND
THEY'RE NOT ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
WHETHER TO DO THIS.
THIS IS LARGELY SYMBOLIC IN
NATURE.
THE COMMITTEE MAY DECIDE THEY
WANT TO MAKE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE THIS WORK
AND COULD SEE IT AS A
CULMINATION.
WE'VE DONE THE HEARINGS,
GATHERED THE EVIDENCE, HOW COULD
WE NOT MAKE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
BUT THIS IS A COMMITTEE
RECONVENING AT A DIFFERENT TIME.
IT'S CLEAR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING AT THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND HIS TOP AIDES ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS.
>> GLORIA, THE FBI SEARCH OF
TRUMP'S MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED THE
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE, I HAVE TO
SAY FROM WHEN THE COMMITTEE HELD
THE LAST HEARING IN JULY.
NOW WE HAVE THE FBI RAIDING
TRUMP'S HOME.
SEARCHING THE HOME FOR
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE COMMITTEE'S
THINKING AS THEY DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT TO REFER?
>> I WAS TALKING TO SOMEBODY
FAMILIAR TO THE COMMITTEE'S
THINKING ON THIS, THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE MEETING.
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEIR NARRATIVE IS.
THEY ALSO, IN A WAY, TAKE SOME
PRIDE IN SAYING WE GOT THIS BALL
ROLLING BECAUSE WE WERE
INTERESTED IN WHAT THE ARCHIVES
HAD, AND THEY WERE ALL
COMPLAINING, IF YOU RECALL, THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WASN'T
DOING ENOUGH OR WASN'T DOING
ANYTHING.
AND NOW, OF COURSE, THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT COMPLAINT.
BUT IN ORDER TO HAVE A COHESIVE
NARRATIVE, THAT SOMEHOW TAKES
MAR-A-LAGO INTO ACCOUNT, EVEN
THOUGH THAT'S SEPARATE FROM
THEIR INVESTIGATION, IS WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
NOW.
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE PUBLIC TO
WATCH.
>> SO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T HAVE THE KIND OF
DEADLINE THAT THE COMMITTEE
PROBABLY HAS.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE COMMITTEE WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO FOLD IF REPUBLICANS TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE IN
NOVEMBER.
WHICH JUST HISTORICALLY IN TERMS
OF VOTES AND -- WILL PROBABLY
HAPPEN.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS STILL
GOING TO BE UNDER BIDEN AND
GARLAND LIKELY, UNTIL -- FOR AT
LEAST A FEW MORE YEARS.
BUT THAT MEANS THAT THE
COMMITTEE DOES HAVE -- THEY'RE
WORKING ON BORROWED TIME.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW DO THEY PRIORITIZE GOING
FORWARD KNOWING THEY PROBABLY
HAVE TO FOLD UP SHOP IN
DECEMBER.
>> THE REALITY IS THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF LOOSE ENDS THE
COMMITTEE HAS TO DEAL WITH.
IN ADDITION TO GETTING THEIR
REPORT IN ORDER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE WORKING ON
GETTING THE FINAL REPORT DONE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THEY'LL
PROBABLY NEVER HEAR FROM, MARK
MEADOWS, DAN SCAVINO AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
WITH THE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS,
LIKE KEVIN McCARTHY, JIM JORDAN,
SCOTT PERRY, PEOPLE RESISTING
APPEARING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO SORT IT
OUT.
>>